right so yeah we talk about perspective
a lot and though it sounds really
repetitive it's very important because
how I see other people situation when
they complain about things not to say
that I'm not empathetic and you can't
complain about things that make you feel
bad but it's really just believing in
the fact that you can't do anything
about your situation that's really hard
for me to really kind of agree with
right so right for example I had a
conversation with a young lady a really
good friend of mine amazing individual
and you know she's working a full-time
job
and she's like um like I kind of worked
towards this thing that I thought was
going to be great and finally at where I
want to be and it's not as great as I
thought and now I have to find a new job
like I don't know what I'm doing and you
know in my mind and you know she's going
on like an hour diatribe about how
terrible her life is but in my opinion
I'm like okay so you somehow managed to
get the successful career that you
wanted in two years that's [ __ ] wild
and you're still [ __ ] young you're
still in your mid-20s which means you
still have a [ __ ] ton of time to figure
out you have no kids no debt no nothing
yeah if life is pretty good right now
man it's all perspective it's all
perspective it's like you have this
ability to now with nothing holding you
down financially or physically yeah and
now you just have to figure out a new
job in like well I've been trying and
like I think like her thing that she was
saying is like well in your career you
could kind of create your own destiny I
was like cool
well if you want my career then work for
it then yeah don't don't don't look it's
not like you [ __ ] [ __ ] in your career
out and you got lucky exactly it fought
for it exactly so it's like if you want
to fight for what I have be my guest
you can but how I got to be where I am
now yeah you're only seeing the ten spot
but you're not seeing number one through
nine that I had to go through to get
here you didn't see the fact that I had
to sell all my [ __ ] to come to this
place you didn't see the fact that I had
a couple hundred dollars in my bank
account living off of ramen with the
[ __ ] spring mattress in a single desk
like you weren't there for that moment
right and I never and I never did this
thing where I show people how lavish I
live because I never got to that point
so it's like it was a it was a very hard
grind for me to end up where I am and I
just showed a lot of gratitude during
that process so I still carry that
gratitude all the way through even when
it was tough when I had these
opportunities to do stand-up without any
pay but I got a five minute
then I got a 10-minute spot you know
what's not fair is that when people see
where we are where we're at or whatever
they go Oh easy for you to say because
all you're doing is talking about you
know how you did it through hard work
but you guys got lucky and to me it's a
lot of [ __ ] when people say that
because what they're doing is they're
discrediting how much sacrifices we made
yeah many [ __ ] 70-hour weeks or
whatever the [ __ ] we did sleepless
nights spending two hours to sleep every
single night for four days straight how
many birthdays we missed families with
things that we there's things that we've
sacrificed to [ __ ] get here yeah but
they're discrediting they're
discrediting all of that and they're
saying well that's because you got lucky
yeah and I'm like okay [ __ ] the
reason why I talk so much [ __ ] and the
reason why I spread this stuff and the
reason why I do it because I care so
much and I want other people to realize
that if you want it to there is an
alternative you don't have to do what
people tell you to do you don't have to
do that there is an alternative there is
a way out if you don't like where you're
at and the only reason why I care so
much is cuz I wish someone told that
[ __ ] to me when I was younger oh yes
right and when I see it in them it
pisses me off because I'm almost kicking
myself saying hey get the [ __ ] up man
yeah so when there are people that are
down and out sure I could approach it in
a more nurturing and loving way but the
frustration comes from a place of god
damn it dude I care so much I want you
guys to realize it I want everyone to
realize it I think there's a huge
problem in our community like the reason
why it's never good enough for a lot of
people is because culturally we're
taught that way from our parents right
go harder go harder you got to get a
pluses whatever so even if you get the
good grade it's like you're supposed to
get the good grade mm-hm you never
celebrate your wins yeah so over the
years I try my best to figure out what
to do in these situations how to rewrite
my program and that's why I came out
with like 90 days to freedom and things
like that because I think people don't
have the
I support and mentality to get out of
the situation that they're in yeah and
also to its you know as I say these
things you know whatever you're going
through though it seems very large and
very hard to get through and as I give
this advice I'm still actually going
through what you're going through I'm
just handling it a lot differently so
I'm still it's a figuring out process
though I am though I have a general idea
of what I want to do now five years from
now four years from now maybe six or ten
it might change and I have to accept
that fact I think that change part
scares a lot of people they go well what
if I do this and then three years down
the line I don't want to do it anymore
that's life [ __ ] that happens all the
time you are not guaranteed anything in
this life the only thing that you're
[ __ ] guaranteed in life is death
that's about the thing is the
uncertainty right it scares you have to
go back to that being confident and not
just masculinity but just being a leader
you have to walk